writing must never be boring it must not
bore the reader the writer it must not
bore anybody you have to have juice in
each line don't you when you write your
words must go like this
they must be full of power they must
make you like to turn a page what these
guys do
[Music]
you see they're too leisurely
they're setting up the scene for the
grand emotion and when they get to the
Grand emotion there isn't any nothing to
analyze there's nothing to say it's just
done
nothing should ever be done that should
be done
it has to come out
like a good hot beer like any other
writer there's no Pace there's no
quickness in his line there's no life
there's no sunlight each line must be an
entity unto itself